Opposers this can't wait
any longer.
Last week unarmed 22 year old
Stephon Clark was fatally
shot by police
20 times in his
grandparents' backyard.
And yesterday the White House
spoke ... about why
they're not speaking.
This is something
that is a local matter.
It should be left up
to the local authorities,
not something for the federal
government to weigh into.
Yes a local issue.
Just look at all
of these local issues
which are all
the fatal police shootings
since Ferguson. Just a bunch
of totally unrelated small town
and big city and medium village
happenstances.
Actually it's kind of
like this morning
I found a mouse in my kitchen.
It's not a big deal.
Granted yesterday
I also found one
in my living room
and in my bedroom, and my shoes,
and actually also ... my living
room.
But whose are all single
isolated mice
with single isolated presence,
they left on my pillowcase.
Now my house doesn't
have a mouse problem.
If it were a big house
wide issue
I would probably have to think
of a systematic way
to address it on a larger scale,
but luckily it's not.
Look, President Trump
doesn't have time to deal
with local issues.
He focuses on larger stories
that affect the nation.
Like calling Roseanne
to congratulate her
on her spectacular ratings.
Congratulations Roseanne.
The fight continues. Good.
You hid down here where
the real truth lies.
You want to help me
defeat globalists?
And stay on the inside?
Click and subscribe
and help me defeat them.
Because following me
on my YouTube channel
makes you a leader.
It tracks, trust me.